oh it's time it's time for the super hot
tension problem we're about to do this
right here we've got our super hot can
of red peppers hanging from these
strings we want to know what the tension
is in these ropes this is for real now
as a real tension problem and here's the
deal you might look at this you might
get frightened you might think I've got
to come up with a completely new
strategy to tackle this I got to throw
away everything I've learned and just
try something new and that's a lie you
should not lie to yourself
use the same process we're going to use
the same process we used for the easy
tangent problems because it's going to
lead us to the answer again be careful
don't don't stray from the strategy here
the strategy works so we're going to
draw our force diagram first that's what
we always do we're going to say that the
forces are force of gravity on this can
of red peppers which is mg and if it's
three kilograms we know three kilograms
times about ten if we're going to say
let's approximate G is ten again to make
the numbers come out nice so instead of
using 9.8 we'll say G is about ten and
so we'll say three kilograms times 10
meters per second squared is going to be
30 Newtons so the force of gravity
downward is 30 Newtons what are the
forces do we have we've got this t1 and
remember tension does not push ropes
can't push ropes can only pull so t1 is
going to pull that way so I'm gonna draw
t1 coming this way so here's our t1 and
then we're going to have t2 pointing
this way so this is t2 again t2 poles
just like all tension tension poles
tension can't push so I've got tension
two going this way that's it that's our
force diagram there's no other forces I
don't draw a normal force because this
can isn't in contact with another
surface so there's no normal force
you've got these two tensions the force
of gravity and now we do the same thing
we always do after our force diagram we
use Newton's second law in one direction
or another so let's do it let's say that
acceleration is the net force in a given
direction divided by the mass which
direction do we pick again it's hard to
say we've got forces vertical we got
forces horizontal there's only two
directions to pick X or Y in this
problem we're going to pick
the vertical direction even though it
doesn't really matter too much but
because we know one of the forces in the
vertical direction we know the force of
gravity force of gravity is 30 30
Newtons usually that's a good strategy
pick the direction that you know
something about at least so I'm going to
do that here we're going to say that the
acceleration vertically is equal to the
net force vertically over the mass and
so now we plug in if this can is just
sitting here if there's no acceleration
if this is not an elevator transporting
these peppers up or down and it's not a
no rocket if it's just seeing here with
no acceleration our acceleration will be
zero that's going to equal the net force
in the vertical direction so what are we
going to have so what are the forces in
the vertical direction here one force is
this 30 Newton force of gravity this
points down we're going to assume upward
is positive that means down is negative
so I'll just put negative 30 Newtons I
could have written negative mg but we
already knew it was 30 Newtons all right
negative 30 Newtons then we've got t1
and t2 both of those point up but they
don't completely point up they partially
point up so part of them points to the
right part of them points upward only
this vertical component we'll call it t1
Y is going to get included into this
calculation because this calculation
only uses Y directed forces and the
reason is only Y directed forces
vertical forces affect the vertical
acceleration so this t1 Y points upward
I'll do plus t1 in the Y direction and
similarly this t2 it doesn't all point
vertically only part of it points
vertically so I'll write this is t2 in
the Y direction and that's also upward
so since that's up I'll count it as plus
t2 in the Y direction and that's it
that's all our forces notice we can't
plug in the total amount t2 into this
formula because only part of it points
up similarly we have to only plug in the
vertical component of the t1 force
because only part of it points
vertically and then we divide by the
mass the mass is three kilograms but
we're going to multiply both sides by
three kilograms we're going to get zero
equals all of this right here so I'll
just copy this right here we use this
over again that comes down right there
but now there's nothing on the bottom
here so what do we do at this point now
you might think we're stuck I mean we
got two unknowns in here I can't solve
for either one I don't know either one
of these I know they have to add up to
30 so what would find if I added 30 to
both sides I'd realize that these two
vertical components of these tension
forces added up have to add up to 30 and
that makes sense they have to balance
the force downward but I don't know
either of them so how do I solve here
well let's do this if you ever get stuck
on one of the force equations for a
single direction just go to the next
equation let's try a in the x-direction
so for a in the x-direction we'd have
the net force in the x-direction over
the mass again the acceleration is going
to be zero if these peppers are not
accelerating horizontally so unless
these things in a train car something in
the whole thing's accelerating then you
might have horizontal acceleration and
if you did it's not that big of a deal
you just plug it in there but assuming
this acceleration zero because the
peppers are just sitting there not
changing their velocity we'll plug in
zero we'll plug in the forces in the
x-direction these are going to be T one
in the X so part of this T one points in
the x direction similarly part of T two
points in the X direction so I'll call
this T two X will use these are the
magnitudes let's say T two x is the
magnitude of the force the T two pulls
with to the left and T 1 X is the
magnitude of the force that T 1 pulls
with to the right so to plug these in
we've got to decide whether they should
be positive or negative so this T 1 X
since it pulls to the right T 1 X will
be positive we're going to consider
rightward to be the positive direction
because that's the typical convention
that we're going to adopt and T 2 X
since it pulls to the left that's going
to be a negative contribution so minus T
2 in the X direction because leftward
would be negative we divide by the mass
the mass was three kilograms but again
we'll multiply both sides by three we'll
get zero equals and then we just get T
the same thing up here so we'll just
copy this thing here put it down here
and again you might be concerned I can't
solve this either I mean I can I can
solve for T 1 X but look at what I get
if I just multiply added T 2 X to both
sides
I'm just going to get t1 in the X
Direction has to equal T 2 in the X
direction and that makes sense these two
forces have to be equal and opposite
because they have to cancel so that you
get no acceleration in the X direction
and this was not drawn proportionately
sorry this should be the exact same size
as this force because they have to
cancel since there's no horizontal
acceleration but what do we do we can't
solve this equation we got from the X
direction we can't solve this equation
we got for the y direction whenever this
happens when you get two equations you
can't solve either because there's too
many unknowns you're going to have to
end up plugging one into the other but I
can't even do that yet I've got four
different variables here t1 X t2 X t1 Y
and t2 y these are all four different
variables I've only got two equations I
can't solve this so the trick the trick
we're going to use that a lot of people
don't like doing because it's a little
more sophisticated now we've got to put
these all in terms of t1 and t2 so that
we can solve if I put t1 Y in terms of
total t1 and then signs of angles and
cosines of angles and I put t2 Y in
terms of t2 and angles I do the same
thing for 1x and 2x I'll have two
equations and the only two unknowns will
be t1 and t2 then we can finally solve
if that didn't make any sense here's
what I'm saying I'm saying figure out
what t1 Y is in terms of t1 so I know
this angle here let's figure out these
angles so these angles here are if this
is 30 this angle down here has to be 30
because these are alternate interior
angles and if you don't believe me
imagine this big triangle right here
where this is a right angle so this
triangle from here to there down to here
up to here if this is 30 that's 90 this
has got to be 60 because it all adds up
to 180 for a triangle and if this right
angle is an ID on this side 60 the sides
got to be 30 similarly this sides a
right angle look at this triangle 60 90
that means this would have to be 30 and
so if I come down here this angle would
have to be 60 just like this one because
it's an alternate interior angle so
that's 60 so this angle here is 60 this
angle here is 30 we can figure out what
these components are in terms of the
total vectors
once we find those we're going to plug
those expressions into here and that'll
let us solve so in other words T 1 Y is
going to be once you do this for a while
you realize this is the opposite side so
this component here is going to be the
total t1 times sine of 30 because it's
the opposite side and if that didn't
make sense we'll derive it right here so
what we're saying is that sine of 30
sine of 30 is opposite over hypotenuse
and in this case the opposite side is t1
y so t1 Y over the total t1 is equal to
sine of 30 and we can solve this for T 1
Y now we can get the t1 Y if I multiply
both sides by t1 I get that that's t1
times sine of 30 so that's what I said
down here t1 is just T oh sorry I forgot
the 1 tu 1 times sine of 30 similarly if
you do the same thing with cosine 30
you'll get the t1 X is t1 cosine 30 by
the exact same process similarly over
here
t2 is going to be our sorry T 2 X is
going to be t2 so t2 cosine 60 because
this is the adjacent side and t2 Y is
going to be t2 sine of 60 and if any of
that doesn't make sense just go back to
the definition of sine and cosine write
what the opposite side is the total
hypotenuse side solve for your
expression you'll get these so if you
don't believe me on those try those out
yourselves but those are what these
components are in terms of t2 and the
angles t2 t1 and the angles and why are
we doing this we're doing this so that
when we plug in over here we'll only
have two variables in other words if I
plug t1 why this expression here t1 sine
30 in 41 Y similarly if I plug in T 2 y
is t2 sine 60 into this expression right
there 42 Y look at what I'll get I'll
get 0 equals so I'll get negative 30
Newtons and then I'll get plus t1 why
was t1
30 so t1 and then sine 30 we can clean
this up a little bit sine 30 is just 1/2
so I'll just write t1 over 2 and then
because sine 30 is just 1/2 and then t2
Y is going to be t2 sine 60 and sine 60
is just root 3 over 2 so I'll write this
as plus T 2 over 2 and then times root 3
and you might think this is no better I
mean this is still an horrible mess
right here but look at this is in terms
of t1 and t2 that's what I'm going to do
over here I'm going to put these in
terms of t1 and t2 and then we can solve
so t1 X is t1 cosine 30 so I'm going to
write this as T 1 times cosine 30 and
cosine 30 is root 3 over 2 so this is T
1 over 2 times root 3 and that should
equal t2 x is right here that's t2
cosine 60 cosine 60 is 1/2 so t2 X is
going to be T 2 over 2 so T 2 over 2 so
what I'm doing is if this doesn't make
sense I'm just substituting what these
components are in terms of the total
magnitude in the angle and I do this
because look what I have now I've got
one equation with t1 and t2 I've got
another equation with t1 and t2 so I'm
going to do to solve these when you have
two equations and two unknowns you have
to solve for one of these variables and
then substitute it into the other
equation that way you'll get one
equation with one unknown and you try to
get the math right and you'll get the
problem so I'm going to solve this one
is easier so I'm going to solve this one
for let's just say t2 so if we solve
this for T 2 I get that T 2 equals well
I can multiply both sides by 2 and I'll
get T 1 times root 3 so t1 times the
root 3 because the 2 here cancels with
this 2 or when I multiply both sides by
2 it cancels out so get the t2 equals t1
root 3 this is great I can substitute t2
as t1 root 3 into here for t2 and the
reason I do that is I'll get one
equation with one unknown I'll only have
t1 in that
now if I do this I'll get zero equals
negative you know let's just move the
negative 30 over this is kind of
annoying here just add 30 to both sides
take this calculation here we'll get
plus 30 equals and then we're going to
have t1 over 2 from this t1 so T 1 over
2 plus I've got plus t2 is t1 root 3 so
when I plug t1 root 3 in 42 what I'm
going to get is I'm going to get t1 root
3 and then times another root 3 because
t2 itself was t1 root 3 so I'm taking
this expression here plugging it in 42
but I still have to multiply that t2 by
a root 3 and divide by 2 and so what do
we get root 3 Times root 3 is just 3 so
I get t1 times three halves plus t1 over
2 so I'll get 30 equals and then I get T
1 over 2 we're almost there I promise T
1 over 2 plus and then this is going to
be t1 times 3 over 2 so it's going to be
3 T 1 over 2 well what does that equal T
1 over 2 plus 3 T 1 over 2 is just just
4 halves so that's just 2 T 1 so this
cleaned up beautifully so this is just 2
times t1 and now we can solve for t1 we
get that t1 is simply 30 divided by 2 if
I divide both sides this left hand side
here by 2 and this side here this right
side by 2 I get t 1 is 30 over 2
Newton's which is just these should be
Newton's I should have units on these
which is just 15 Newton's whoo I did it
15 Newton's t 1 is 15 Newtons we got t1
that's one of them how do we get the
other you start back over at the very
beginning nah not really that would be
terrible
you actually just take this t1 and you
plug it right into here boot there he
goes so t2 we already got it t2 is just
t1 root 3 so all I have to do is
multiply root 3 by my t1 which I know
now I get the t2 is just 15 times root 3
Newtons so once you get one of the
forces the next one's really easy this
is just T 2 so T 2 is root 15 root 3 and
T 1 is just 15 so in case you got lost
in the details the big picture recap is
this we drew a force diagram we use
Newton's second law in the vertical
direction we couldn't solve because
there were two unknowns we use Newton's
second law in the horizontal direction
we couldn't solve because there were two
unknowns we put all four of these
unknowns in terms of only two unknowns
t1 and t2 by writing how those
components depended on those total
vectors we substituted these expressions
in for each component once we did that
we had two equations with only t1 t2 and
t1 and t2 in them we solved one of these
equations for t2 in terms of t1
substituted that into the other equation
we got a single equation with only one
unknown we were able to solve for that
unknown once we got that which is our t1
once we have that variable we plug it
back into that first equation that we
had solved for t2 we plug this 15 in we
get what the second tension is so even
when it seems like Newton's second law
won't get you there if you have faith
and you persevere you will make it good
job